hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast clinical controversies and
vitamin D testing and treatment I'm
Alice farrago of di sauron and I'll be
your moderator for today's event we are
delighted to bring you this education
web seminar presented by lab roots and
sponsored by dias Ornan dias Oren is a
global leader in the field of
biotechnology for more than 40 years the
company has been developing producing
and commercializing reagent kits for in
vitro diagnostics worldwide it offers
the broadest range of specialty tests
available in the immunodiagnostic market
and continually invest research and
development using its own distinctive
expertise in the field of immuno
diagnostics to deliver a high level of
innovation for more information please
visit dia sorne com we have a few
important announcements before we begin
this webcast is designed to be
interactive and we encourage you to ask
questions during the event you can
submit questions by typing them in the
Q&A box which can be found by clicking
on the green Q&A button in the lower
left of the presentation window we'll
try to answer as many questions as we
can you can enlarge the slide window by
clicking on the screen icon in the lower
right hand corner of a slide window if
you have any technical problems viewing
our hearing this presentation please
click on the support button at the top
right of your presentation window or
submit your problem through the green
Q&A button lower left this is an
educational webinar and thus offers free
continuing education credits after the
webinar is over please click on the cee
button located in the bottom left corner
of your web page and follow the process
of obtaining your credits I would now
like to introduce today's speaker dr.
Gregory plotnikov Gregory plotnikov is a
board-certified internist and
pediatrician and act
clinical practice who has received
numerous national and international
awards for research and education he is
the lead author of one book 23 textbook
chapters and more than 50 articles in
peer-reviewed medical literature his
2003 article on vitamin D deficiency and
chronic and nonspecific musculoskeletal
pain is one of the most highly cited
articles in the history of mayo clinic
proceedings he is a graduate of Carleton
College Harvard University divinity
school and the University of Minnesota
Medical School I will now turn it over
to dr. regular Gregory plotnikov for his
presentation well hello everyone I
understand we're back online if you're
still here thank you so very much and I
apologize for technical difficulties
this is most unexpected and everything
been so thank you for your patience
let's move forward because you're all
are interested in vitamin D is a hot
topic assuming we need to know about and
so let's just do a quick review the
slide you have before you right now is
from the netter series as something that
every medical student has been caught
for that's umpteen number of decades um
that is you see where some shine
sunlight ultraviolet be a certain range
striking the skin you know precipitates
a chemical reaction that that then gets
goes to liver for further hydroxylation
at erics me for this first hydroxylation
then on to kidney for a second
hydroxylation creating an active product
125 dihydroxy vitamin D which is not a
vitamin at all bye normal understanding
vitamins being cofactors this is a
hormone and this value bind sublime
indeed receptors found throughout the
body and which would actually regulate
gene expression for hundreds or perhaps
even
more genes in our body and so a big
concern that want you to know about is
that actually what medical students had
not been taught for many years is the
fact that there are activating enzymes
throughout the body not just the kidney
and so you have all kinds of autocrine
and paracrine and endocrine effects of
this hormone acting locally and
systemically vitamin D is very important
and so recent research has introduced
new understandings about the vitamin D
receptor about the different enzymes for
activation and deactivation of the
active form of vitamin D and there's
also been interest in vitamin D binding
protein today we're going to focus on
what is well established and what is we
considered the evidence base for vitamin
D but big point is that vitamin D
consciousness has to be part of a
reality there's in fact we all suffer
somewhat from nature deficit disorder
they spend long hours indoors in air
conditioning we generally and when we do
go outside we have clothing on where r
have sunscreen on we live in places like
here in Minnesota and halfway to the
North Pole the only link vitamin D in a
very narrow range of the Year
supplementation is really important now
this a bit well understood in this
famous picture from Life magazine you
see during era of Lenin in soviet russia
and here are children standing around
and ultraviolet be emitting light and
getting there ryland e in the midst of
winter i thought oh isn't this an
interesting picture and isn't this
reflection of some kind of archaic
understanding no I choose as a very
progressive understanding that yes if
you're living in Siberian
far north and 24 hour day darkness you
you're not going to get vitamin D from
anywhere else unless and in that we
really need to encourage so as an issue
well we think about it maybe in advanced
industrial society like the you ned
kingdom well ed yes you know there's
kind of all kinds of articles Camille
about we're seeing more more rickets and
from the 2013 and in fact it's a big
concern of the world health organization
is to the medicine other groups have
taken on this issue because in fact you
say how could this possibly happen there
was something from the time of Dickens
and and the like but in fact in 2010
into medicine did report on this and I
say yes vitamin D is playing a key role
in bone health they say but the current
evidence does not support other benefits
for vitamin D let's unpack this story
and set the context around it in 2008
the British Medical Journal published a
review article vitamin D which addressed
if I'm d deficiency causes and
consequences the author Michael hoek
professor of medicine at Boston
University Medical School delineate very
clearly that the existing literature at
the time demonstrating a very strong
correlation of low vitamin D states with
multiple multiple multiple medical
concerns our correlation is not and do
not represent causality and so with more
and more public interest in this low
cost low toxicity possibly very helpful
intervention Institute of Medicine
National Academy of Sciences United
States hold together a blue blue ribbon
committee to really address this that's
when they said yes the vitamin evidence
does demonstrate that vitamin D is
crucial for bone health
but they said all the other correlations
that have been well documented the
evidence was not strong enough that is
they were not double-blind randomized
placebo-controlled clinical trials or
meta analyses of clinical trials
demonstrating both safety and efficacy
of supplementation now with this on the
Institute Medicine said that well
actually we're going to redefine what is
kind of normal level and down to 20
nanograms per ml by blood measurement
and we're going to say that North
Americans in general with few exceptions
few exceptions have sufficient vitamin D
and we are going to triple the
recommendation for intake from 200
international units to 600 international
units per day now I should note that the
World Health Organization's
recommendations at 200 international
units per day no matter where you live
whether you live at the North Pole or
whether you live in the equatorial
tropics whether you're 600 pounds or six
pounds is kind like pretty much the same
what you're black or white doesn't
necessarily really reflect good science
so but that is where we are today going
to the next slide here in 2011 found me
2010 report and the world's foremost
organization scientific based
organization on endocrine related issues
and rukan society said they'd really
like to see people greater than equal to
13 anagrams karemma calm so also you
have a controversy right there is it 20
is it 30 how you hug you decide well
part of the concern is that actually
there was a big question but while
looking at the data the Institute of
Medicine put a lot of weight on this one
study
looking at 675 cadavers people who died
in accidents in Germany throughout the
year they did measure their blood level
of vitamin D at the time of death and
their bone mineral density and kind of
assessment of bone strength you can see
on the the x-axis that blood levels of
vitamin D ranged quite a bit as you note
that it is Nana moles per liter so it's
2.5 times higher than nanograms per ml
so the Eye Institute of Medicine
recommended the cutoff being 20
nanograms or per ml or fifteen animals
per liter as you see that on the line
here why what was of great interest was
actually these know right here and that
is people with with I've seen as having
weak bones and good vitamin D levels and
so the Institute of Medicine said 20 but
many other people said no it should have
been right here at 30 to ensure that
everyone has a good bone mineral density
now of course there's a big difference
because bone vitamin D levels can vary
throughout the year and bone mineral
density does not vary throughout the
year so you have a stock and flow
challenge so in case you people are
saying the numbers aren't really all
that compellingly strong and so now
we're in this kind of place where a lot
of different agendas are coming out the
public health agenda is what amount we
need to give people can sure that 97.5
percent of the population avoid an index
disease such as rickets
and I think we should consider
osteoporosis another key issue clinical
trial list say don't supplement because
we need to establish causality and we
don't want in confounding issues their
clinical trials are saying telling
clinicians don't supplement because it's
literally to quote some publishing an
editorial in JAMA threatens our capacity
do randomized controlled trials in
normal populations in clinicians are
saying I bet mrs. Jones in front of me
she's suffering um I need to measure and
supplementary vitamin D no matter what
the clinical trial is say its low cost
as low toxicity if it has a big bang for
the buck great and we'll know within a
month and then clinicians in the public
and clinicians are still saying you know
wait for the red lines controlled trials
the public is saying hey waiting I've
got a huge deductible for my health
insurance you know are you telling me I
cannot make the bet that if I put five
cents a day in divided Lindy I might
save myself a lot of money so lots of
competing issues here lots of competing
agendas lots of concerns and we're going
to see these play out and in the media
in a variety of ways and we also see
playing out in in funding agendas as
well so so competing priorities we
recover these I'm just going to jump
ahead but you know Skype I want to
report that in 2012 the Surgeon General
said hey wait a second osteoporosis is a
major threat to Americans and it's
preventable and how we prevent make sure
you get enough vitamin D well how do
what is enough is it is that World
Health Organization's 200 air not
showing it today is it into the
medicines on a recommendation for 600
Air National
today is it 6,000 their natural units a
day it's a very good question we can
only know by measurement I can tell you
as a clinician there really is no really
good physical exam for any kind of blood
test that would replace a blood test you
cannot look at someone say I bet your
cholesterol levels to 20 same thing as
you can't say I bet your vitamin D level
is new 26 can't say it just does not
exist measurements the only way to
address that and so in 2015 is a very
powerful editorial in the journal
American Medical Association based in
there pleading don't measure don't
supplement because it threatens our
capacity to conduct randomized control
trials and usual risk populations well
wait a second whose agenda is at play
here and so looking at this let me
introduce you a case very powerful case
so um why we should be paying more
attention time looking at vitamin D
forty-eight-year-old is a physician he's
got diabetes get hypertension risk
factors for cardiac disease but he's not
doing well he's got palpitations he's
he's precinct a bully is about to pass
out increasing shortness of breath he
comes in for exam he's in florid heart
failure not a good place to be and not
expected with someone his age with no
previous concerns and so you see a chest
x-ray really clear no question this is
heart failure we and take a look at
what's going on with his EKG you can
tell even if you're not clinician you
know this is not normal the heart is all
over the place is beating way too fast
they will keep blood pressure up this is
a very abnormal situation an emergency
situation not well explained the most
likely cause is going to be
this is going to be severe heart failure
is probably due to the heart not getting
enough oxygen so of course you rush this
patient into the angiographic sweet you
take a look at the heart vessels you
plan to stent or bypass but everything
comes back normal huh what's going on
well let's get back to the room and
let's think about this so he's back in
the room he needs going on ventilatory
support he's having a lots of episodes
of v-tach are we medication is being
tried you have to kind of charge him up
again and multiple times that's not
solving the problem he actually it was
in well what's going on well let's take
a look at some blood tests and common
blood tests being done for different
steroids and different things in unusual
situations and will be hauled his
calcium is very low and lo and behold
his parathyroid hormone is very high huh
as I mean D is really low well can't do
anything else that's the only abnormal
thing we found so let's at least treat
his vitamin D as your back of them say
most places in the United States North
America say hey this guy needs a heart
transplant get him on the list right
away we can't do anything else we can't
pace them out of this we can't do
anything heart transplant but this was
India and there were no heart
transplants available in this region so
what do you then do well how about some
vitamin D and calcium at least do that
well what happened steady improvement in
his vital signs sinus rhythm no need to
cardiovert and heart sighs returns to
normal lungs clear and this is all
confirmed by MRI
of his heart so is this interesting
situation this is where the clinicians
issue comes in and say hey look it's low
cost low toxicity you know we spent
maybe ten dollars in vitamin D and
calcium versus 250 to 500 thousand
dollars for a heart transplant how do we
weigh this let's do this even if there
isn't randomized controlled trial data
supporting this so this was published in
the annals of internal medicine one the
leading medical journals of the world
and so this is people say well why
should we be doing this in the absence
of double-blind randomized controlled
trials and public is asking about this
too so for example if you've got a high
deductible plan and let's say you've got
a potentially expensive situation coming
up like your birth of a child we know
that one day in a newborn intensive care
unit can be easily forty five hundred
dollars people say well shouldn't uh
what can I do to minimize the risk of
this because I don't spend my deductible
on this so if we look at vitamin D and
prenatal health we know that there are
strong correlations with impaired
insulin sensitivity gestational diabetes
a major risk factor bacterial vaginosis
a risk factor caranto disease a risk
factor preeclampsia something we
definitely want to avoid emergencies
suction definitely want to avoid but in
vitro fertilization failure and maternal
depression all correlated with vitamin D
status and for the newborn now low
maternal vitamin D is correlated with
small for gestational age correlated
with birth weight and birth length and
head circumference and calcium levels
and immune function I'll strongly
correlated with remedies status and for
the child themselves strong correlations
with bone mineral content
cavities infections including our sv
bronchiolitis common cause admission to
the hospital and winter season allergies
wheezing atopic dermatitis eating
disorders and children obesity and
neuropsychological development yeah
child IQ linked so five cents a day for
vitamin D or should we wait wait for the
randomized control trials and that's
where we get all kinds of concerns know
if you think about IQ and your children
is this kind well were this and where is
this being published with being
published in things like pediatrics
pediatrics leading journals of the world
pediatrics um you know these are kind of
this is this is not kind of like you
know kind of out on too much debt either
kind of rigorous places to get published
its most competitive journal world in
pediatrics is to publish in the journal
Pediatrics of the american academy of
pediatrics so there's good reason to
consider that at least there's a link
even if we can't prove causality at this
time so but weirder things go when
American College of obstetrics and
gynecology is said hey look at there's
time' there's insufficient evidence
meaning randomized control trial double
blinded and meta-analyses of this to
super supportive recommendation for
screening for all pregnant women ok
let's reasonable but additionally
recommendations concerning routine
supplementation let's wait until we get
more data published and so a very
conservative approach and so you get the
public clamoring for a normal vitamin D
levels and you get medical profession
saying let's wait for the data to prove
that this is good effective and safe so
two different types of advocacy going on
so where do we fall on this one all
lives is a value judgment of course and
so I need to share with you the
five facts today that important for you
to share with are your friends and
neighbors and colleagues number one is
vitamin D is not a violent it is a
hormone and it affects gene expression
for hundreds if not thousands of genes
the vitamin D receptors found throughout
the body and includes every brain cell
heart cell liver cell lung cell immune
cell bone marrow cell muscle cell the
vitamin D receptor is there for a reason
number three is actually we often don't
get enough of vitamin D in diet or we're
not making enough because we just don't
have exposure to the Sun anymore and
then likewise for those who are doing
research or evaluating research we have
to say look unrecognized efficiency
unacknowledged not addressed confounds
both medical care and medical research
and or certain things in my opinion need
to be ruled out such as vitamin D
deficiency before certain diagnosis can
be made so were the additional
controversies well there are many so
controversy number one is what is normal
what's a normal level and hell is normal
these are obviously are very profoundly
political questions and so in a normal
brain show is based upon what's
considered a kind of reference
population we look at two different
types of refuse reference populations
say office workers like myself or like
lifeguards farmers and the like and get
two really different levels of what
concerns me normal so an office worker
like myself you compared to lifeguards
you know like our to about two and a
half times higher levels of vitamin D
but which population is quote normal
well I'm an office worker I'm normal so
therefore that must be the reference
population but it doesn't necessarily
need to be the case you know it isn't
necessarily normal for the human being
to be living in a cave all day long and
so if we look at vitamin D levels and
outdoor workers here we have the
institute of medicine's recommendation
for a 20 here we have the the endocrine
society to recommendation for 30 but
where are we seeing things come through
wall porto rican farmers mean levels you
know somewhere low 50s lifeguards in st.
Louis Missouri levels around 64 Israeli
lifeguards levels around 60 is that
really normal so in fact actually this
is really questions our IOM's
recommendation of what is normal
controversy number two you know kind
that is this whole idea about the index
disease recommended daily allowance I
supposed to be an amount that you take
in to prevent and index disease and
therefore that is good for the entire
person index disease for vitamin D has
been rickets now we see one prevent
rickets but is a prime indeed connection
with anything else index diseases tend
them short latency what about long-term
issues so so you think about you know
classic things a deficiency very very
pellagra scurvy things we never hear
about any more in rickets but what if
there's something more than just rickets
that provide Maddie being important and
so long latency diseases you say like
cancer hypertension diabetes we're not
considering them and what about if there
is more than just bone involvement what
if that vitamin D receptor and other
tissues is
role in some regard and what if we say
that oh we too easily write off
diagnosis to an ngon vitamin D related
cause when in fact actually could be
vitamin D say like fibromyalgia or Falls
or osteopenia etc so controversy number
three and that is the recommendation 400
international units per day which you
find in North America is what the
general amount you find in a
multivitamin where does that number come
from the 400m measurements I have to
tell you come from one article published
in nineteen forty in the journal
American Medical Association and the
exact he was an article by MIDI it was
an article on rickets and two paragraphs
in that lengthy article addressed by
Mandy and they say well look at these
white kids in Boston who don't have
rickets why is it oh they're doing cod
liver oil oh how much a tablespoon a day
okay how much vitamin D in the
tablespoon all about 400 air naturally
it's okay that's our recommendation yes
that's it for the science that is
repeated in 1963 pediatrics article and
pretty much taking that's gospel truth
ever since hmm how strong is the science
in behind this controversy number four
you need to know about oh if I just go
out 15 minutes a day that will be enough
well that may be true if you're in the
summer and your between hours of ten and
three and you're not wearing sunscreen
and you happen to be white and thin and
young and so actually you know in the
southern United States that's kind of
t but you know further north you go is
that really going to be the case no
actually it's not at all and so in fact
we look at here in Minneapolis at 45
degrees north halfway to the North Pole
you can see that actually there is a
really kind of nice bell curve
throughout the year for ultraviolet well
we can see also why you know it's kind
of mid-april to kind of like early to
mid-september is about the only time it
can really make vitamin D by being out
in the Sun here in Minnesota but we're
surprising is that look at this even in
the middle of the kind of high season
making vitamin D the actual um you kind
of vitamin D producing raise reaching
the ground can vary quite a bit
depending upon smog to bang upon
overhead and if clouds and the like and
see if you can ever if you ever flown
into an airport sunny day you see kind
of brown haze across the horizon that
consider that Brown haze that smog to be
a vitamin D umbrella may seem be sunny
on the ground but you may not be gained
the Rays to make the vitamin D add on
top of that clothing and sunscreen and
you're really not going to be making
vitamin D and so it's a big concern and
last concern was that that the committee
emphasizes that this is the Institute of
Medicine with a few exceptions all North
Americans are receiving enough vitamin D
so the question are there well who had
exceptions so the exceptions are
surprisingly number one immigrants and
refugees in fact if we look at once day
was involved in looking nearly 1400 new
here to Minnesota you know more than
half words deficient a good percentage
were severely deficient
and and it's all had to do with origin
and that is almost all the ethiopians
people from East Africa they're coming
here with dark skin the more color in
one's skin no more Sun one needs to make
the same amount of vitamin D and someone
with less color in their skin and so
profound difference between white
russians and black Ethiopians and
profound differences that actually a lot
of these folks who were actually quite
young and I was also surprised and more
so than the elderly hmm why is that I
guess we're all inside on screens a lot
of the day so in fact actually common
things saying 15 minutes a day why keeps
going to vary a lot in depending on
color of your skin and where you live
and how much time you can actually get
outside so going to the next slide here
clicking ahead wait for response excuse
me okay so let's take a look at centers
for disease control data what we're
looking at this National Health and
Nutrition evaluation surveys from two
different years or two different trials
and what you see is the most recent
trial across the board by ages by
genders and by ethnicities that across
the board vitamin D levels appear to
have dropped significantly now there may
be some issues around technical testing
but let's take a look at other issues
let's look at profoundly low vitamin D
levels less than 10 nanograms per ml
it's going up across the board in all
age groups it's going up significantly
between men and women
and there's a profound variance among
different groups in fact people with
dark skin in this case blacks nearly
30-percent have profoundly low vitamin D
levels according to for the Centers for
Disease Control so question is most
Americans with few exceptions have
levels greater than 20 who are those
exceptions or identified refugees and we
identified ethnic minorities huh what's
going on here and if we look at levels
better than what we want to see
according to the endocrine society again
across the board by pages and by genders
and by ethnicities it has dropped so we
have more people who are being
profoundly deficient and we have less
people who are sufficient across the
board are you one of you know anyone run
among them I have to say this is true
for all North Americans this is a big
concern and if you consider that 45
degrees north is the equivalent of
southern France the French Spanish
border have say a huge percent of Europe
would be at risk as well based on just
sun exposure data so looking at this
issue more specifically at 45 degrees
north here in Minnesota in the spring
2010 and we look at 10,000 646 employees
of a health care system predominantly
female predominantly nurses everyone had
great access to health care and
presumably more knowledgeable than the
lay public and Erin had health insurance
and
and ready access to to care what kinda
did we see looking at vitamin D levels
and that well this group you know it's
kind of we should also say that the
local paper had run many articles and
vitamin D deficiency prior to the
testing and so you think the government
should be doing well we tested it all in
the spring a very narrow time period and
his results 10,000 646 we found 643 you
know about six percent of the population
had levels less than 10 were profoundly
low we found that another thirty percent
were had levels less than the institute
of medicine's recommendation you say
we're wasting it the few exceptions how
could this be and even if we look at
going further to get levels greater than
20 still you know it's kind of a huge
percent had levels less than 30 how
could this be this is probably the least
risk oriented group that is you think
about maybe people who are disconnected
from medical system don't have health
insurance they don't have a good
understanding of how thin well-being and
physiology huh how could this be so in
fact there's a part of reason why is a
webinars like this are so important and
why it's important for you to share this
with your neighbors into skype plays in
this is a big issue in our country if
it's true for health professionals how
many other people can be true for so
going to the next slide here we took a
look then specifically at women of
childbearing age and this is about 6,500
women and we took a look at how
what they reported for intake of vitamin
D and here you see kind of on the x-axis
you've got intake report y axis is
measured level and these are mean levels
and lo and behold across the board
everyone has main level greater than the
Institute of medicines recommendation
yay okay so that's good for a main level
but what percent actually achieved
greater than 29 grams per ml by levels
so if we take a look at a good
recommendation like institute of
medicine's report people were taking a
prenatal vitamin pre taking a
multivitamin won't behold it's only a
small fraction that people actually meet
that level so what's true are looking at
population as a whole is not true for
individuals you might say when on
average for most people you know a
multivitamin day may be sufficient for
ensuring a bare minimum vitamin D level
20 nanograms per ml but in fact in
practice that is not the case and I
notice that this is also for people with
a BMI less than 34 people would be mines
greater than 30 which is a large percent
of our population these numbers go up
significantly more that is a bigger or
BMI the higher the dose we need to
ensure the same blood level some of the
smaller BMI so facts to share number one
is kind of female health care workers a
child bearing age have a high incidence
of low vitamin D and taking a prenatal
vitamin or multivitamin doesn't ensure
adequate levels and BMI greater than 30
is increased risk factor for low vitamin
D hmmm prenatal vitamin may not be
enough well how can you know that well
and that's the point that we need to
measure and so that would be the
argument for making a measurement but if
you can't know what's where someone is
going to be you can undergo see an
overdose the only guide is to actually
measure so bone health it's the one
thing we can hang our levels on and we
can say that the clinical data actually
suggested bone mineral density has found
it levels much greater than 20 and this
is based on a variety of reports going
back many years and for example if we
take a look at it doesn't stage with
forty thousand participants level 29
grams is not enough to prevent either
fractures or Falls but higher levels do
and again being published in some of the
leading medical journals of the world
but it may be confounders they may have
stayed calcium at the same time and they
may not have been measuring actual
cutoff thresholds how can say is that
you need levels greater than 20 it
appears based on these 12 studies with
40,000 participants so other interesting
facts calcium absorption appears to be
optimized at levels greater than 32 and
simply increasing a vitamin D level from
20 to 32 improves calcium absorption by
sixty-five percent Wow so a
recommendation for calcium intake have
to be based also upon what if I'm in D
level one has if one is running low
you're going to need a singly higher
intake
then someone running high they're going
to need much less of an intake
parathyroid hormone if we plot vitamin D
levels versus parathyroid hormone we
know that there is an inflection point
at greater than 20 and it's minimized at
levels greater at 40 we can say that
based on the study of the 10,000 646
health care employees that people
reported really high level of them take
we're running really similarly high
levels to begin with I'm doing at
similarly high levels and that the body
has the capacity to create a homeostatic
balance depending on where it needs to
be so words that leave us right now well
there's a lot of challenges that we need
to think about and gain good research
moving forward you know is a difference
between dose and serum level yeah one
size fits all doesn't fit for large and
small northern and southern black and
white you know kind of big and fin one
size doesn't fit all we need focus on
serum levels second thing is one thing
is to replenish its a whole nother thing
to make maintain and there's a big
difference between a vitamin D to a
prescription-strength with a very short
half-life and if I'm in d3 the over
counter over-the-counter form with a
half-life of three weeks or more much
like what one would get by going out to
the beach and get a half life about
three weeks or so but vitamin D produced
additionally there is a whole issue
about activated vitamin D called
calcitriol the 125 dihydroxy vitamin D
people suggest maybe we should just be
giving that everyone and bypass the
body's natural capacities to make
remedy as it sees fit and where it sees
fit it's an interesting question again
full value judgments behind that and
then there are kind of different
confounders for example that there are
certain medications which reduce by
mcgee levels like dexamethasone or st.
John's wort the herb rifampin and a
variety of things I'm certainly a
smoking obesity in take some exposure
these are all potential confounders for
things and then we have the question
about the polymorphisms and vitamin D
receptor and activating and deactivating
enzymes and vitamin D binding protein
this is where good research in future is
going to be going to help us better
understand these natural variations i
can say that based on my work in in
genomics that there are great
variability environment d receptor
binding status and there are at least
four key polymorphisms which appear to
have correlations with health effects
and the interpretation my part is that
for people with vomit d receptor
polymorphisms hypothesis that needs to
be tested do these people do better with
even higher levels than other people
there's a biological plausibility behind
the hypothesis and we're waiting data on
that so to kind of conclude about what
we need people to know the population is
that you know vitamin D is not a vitamin
it's a hormone it relates many many many
many genes in our body and the
environment D receptors on many key
organs including brain both the
cognitive and emotional parts of the
brain the immune system our muscles are
bone marrow every organ you can think of
and that has mostly inside living people
and
North America and in Europe we just
aren't gained the sun exposure to make
vitamin D most of us live too far north
for most of the year to make vitamin D
even if we're outside sunny day at high
noon stark naked in the public square we
still might not make a drop of vitamin D
diet and come environments are not
likely to be enough in North America
evening I'm indeed fortified milk but
you have been drinking kinda like a you
know a gallon or two gallons a day day
after day and I don't recommend that for
anyone and that there's a lot of fifth
point is that there's a lot of
unrecognized deficiency out there and
that confounds a medical care and
medical research and so we can add false
positive false negative studies we need
be paying more attention to this as an
important factor in outcomes and so take
home points today is kinda like hey
there's a blood test is available that
25-hydroxyvitamin d blood test is easily
done in clinic it doesn't require
fasting and it gives us a number we want
to have numbers greater than 32 I
believe with a PTH less than 50 and this
is different from the Institute of
medicines recommendation of greater than
20 but as incorporating other thoughts
and this of course is going to be
revised in years to come but there's a
general guideline the way to do this is
through supplementation for most people
supplement supplement supplement and
monitor and recognize that medication
like prednisone and other steroids
different anti-seizure medications and
like consuming lower levels and key
point is that this 15-minute in the Sun
rule doesn't make any sense because it's
not a one-size-fits-all approach and the
greater the BMI the more sun exposure we
need and more color in our skin the work
sun exposure we need the more tobacco
smoke exposure the more
screen we use more clothing we wear the
more hours we spend indoors the more so
exposure we need to make vitamin D and
so key point is you go see your doctor
there's no physical exam for vitamin D
the only really understand by a blood
level and measurement measurement
measurement understand supplementation
supplementation supplementation so at
this point i think that i want to thank
you everyone for your participation and
pure listening in this i hope i've been
helpful and i want to address some of
your questions I appreciate your hang
out longer than then we've gone and so
so we're going to ask you to kind of
type in your questions here and the
first question we have is why don't we
just supplement and bypass measurement
all together so thank you for that
question and yes we can so let's say
what how much do we supplement so if i
go back to clint this afternoon it's how
everyone take five thousand
international units a day would that be
good and perhaps but we're certainly
going to be over supplementing some
people and that wouldn't make sense and
for others we could still be under
supplementing in my experience people
can have more than 10,000 natural unit
today requirements to chi replenish you
think about the bigger the BMI and the
less exposure so I'm supposed to enhance
or are confounding medications or other
things the bottom line is there is no
one-size-fits-all as much as we would
like that simplicity and that's why our
clinical
active measurement is so important and a
second question is is there a way to get
one's doctor to order this test so well
a lot of doctors say that's very nice
mrs. Jones just go ahead and take a
multivitamin or as one doctor said
recently here in town um just eat more
broccoli well key point here is actually
there's no vitamin D in broccoli and
there's minimal vitamin D even in good
healthy foods like Sam and their eggs
and fortified milk you have to think
about 400 mara national units per quart
or about 1600 international units per
gallon and some people do require 5000
initiatives a day so what's that three
gallons a day um day after day after day
I don't think so and so a big point here
is actually since there is not a
one-size-fits-all it's really went
through measurement they can really know
where people are to begin with some
people are just fine on their
multivitamin day or their diet or their
sun exposure and those people don't need
to be supplemented at all other people
are profoundly low and and so to really
understand where people are it's a key
key issue um a third question that
people had is are you sure there's no
physical exam for low vitamin D and say
well yes let's clarify that a little bit
people with profoundly low levels will
be essentially in wheelchairs will be
weak and they will be and so a quick
test is to have people placing hands
across their arms on their shoulders and
actually have them stand up and
five times really quickly those people
who can't do it real quickly those
people who have to put their stock push
themselves up that's low vitamin D until
proven otherwise and a number of young
people who have had their lives severely
impacted by being told that they're
whiners or complainers because they are
weak and achy and they and and no one
considered low vitamin D most poignant
case I'll wrap up with here is a young
woman I saw she came to my clinic she
had had five years progressive
musculoskeletal pain and weakness she
saw numerous doctors they wanted to
offer they Tigers fibromyalgia
depression it was kind of like you know
she's a whiner but no this is someone
who loved going to the gym and and so
from age 30 to 35 she's came
progressively weaker literally and she
games so we could she could barely stand
up at the kitchen counter to do to dish
dude the dishes and her two children
were taken away from her he came to see
me and went out to greet her in the
waiting room n and she wishes her hand
I'm here to hi nice to meet you I'm just
kinda like oh my god 35 year old
african-american woman a progressive
weakness this is vitamin D deficiency
until proven otherwise her vitamin D
levels came back profoundly low we got
her on vitamin D and calcium and
literally you know it says kind of you
know how much do we spend on vitamin D I
don't know you know twenty thirty
dollars in vitamin D and she gets her
two children back no not going
randomized control trials than that but
from a clinical perspective and her say
all we need to consider this in our
differential diagnosis
for every mystery illness and for
everything that that has maybe anyone
with severe illness it's so easy to
check your vitamin D it's so easy
replenish it you see results fairly
quickly either works or it doesn't why
wait 10-15 years two randomized control
trials and if so that's my opinion I
said we should be doing more measurement
more supplementation obviously there are
other people who think otherwise but
that's what the data is for and I'm glad
that we're all connecting the data and I
see no other questions right now we've
gone over thank you for your patience
today thank you very much I'm wishing
all of you the very best of health and I
look forward any questions that you want
to send afterwards thank you take care